*slurp juice*
Edited in drinking (gulping) sounds
WOW (waaaoowww sounds)
New merch available; it's an entirely original concept.
(laughs)
You can finally embrace that you're working at a fast-food restaurant
Everybody
whack Donald's it's a place to be
Designed by me hooray
It's got Walmart quality.
It's a limited offer
Enough dabbing.
Let's begin the video
It's a video I have been wanting to make for a very long time.
I want to check out my most popular videos
(dun dun dun sounds plays in background)
I haven't checked in a very very long time.
It's one of those things
I just don't look at. It's delving into the past and I don't like it. The three phases of Pewdiepie
Do I look stupid? cuz I think I look pretty high
*fridays with pewdiepie*
It's been a while haven't
Hasn't it. English
*epic bridge scene*
What a fucking—
*laughs*
Yeah, I don't know if I like phase three
The thing is, I know my most popular videos are gonna be really old. You know what, let's just get this over with. Sort by...
Most popular. Most people associate a channel by their most popular videos; it-it's pretty obvious. A funny montage
83 million views. God damn!
I had no idea. If I had guessed, I would say it got 40 million views.
How?
Who's watching this and why? Five years ago
First of all, if you call something funny, it's immediately not funny. So this video should be great
I feel like the mother fuckin stuck in this duck
It makes me wanna quack like what the fuck is that?
Oh. Oh. You gonna make a tower. Make a tower.
Go left. Yes that's right.
That's not right you call that right, whamen?
No.
Hold it.
Hold it!
*screams like a girl*
A good example of loud equals funny. You really did it there, Felix. Good job
I love that game. That is a really good...
Man, that's terrible. You can't even see what's going on. I did like how I had this...
heartbeat sensor
That's pretty cool. That's pretty original
You were always there beside me
*laughs*
Oh, I remember this.
Okay, fine, this one is still funny
Oh shit
Why do you know-- What man I look so crazy. I look at me; I look insane
Alright, okay, it's funny. It's kind of funny
A lot of it is cringy but I get why people think it's funny. My second most viewed video is level
level seven of
scare PewDiePie
53 million views
GOD
*rabies*
As stressful as these were to film, not just because of
Me trying to keep up with everything that was going on. But also the show itself like going through all these traumatic experiences
I always look back on it like really fun memories. They were good times. It's a shame
They put this as the the free episode cuz I think it's one of the weaker ones
I think just because it was Outlast, people thought it would be cool
52 million views! The Ruby Play Button. But it's one of those video... that haircut Felix like what in the world?
I remember the guy that gave me that haircut. He was like we're gonna do something different. I'm like, oh, okay
I don't know what it is with packages...
That is so f....n exciting. I really wish I could just be an unboxing channel. That would just be so much fun. Oh
I guess there's really nothing interesting here. We literally just I'm glad we squeezed this one out to ten minutes
And look people just want to know what the award was it's a terrible video funny gaming montage what is this six years ago
Damn, I think we're going here. Should we just leave Jeremy? What? Yes
Jeremy brings these things to us, sir
Just like he always wanted that's my dream with Oliver
WE SHIP PEWDS AND CRY
It was genuinely funny I forgot about that
That's nice, I'm glad I could genuinely enjoy it a clip that's that's fantastic
This is great. I thought I would just cringe. That's hilarious
Locate the entrance to Alpha Labs 4... What does this say?
Death is coming
You don't know
It's like those moderately funny perfect timing twitch
Donation montage or whatever. I don't know. I guess I'm done here Jimbo. Oh, that was close
whoa
Somebody out there
I like how I took the chair with me as well
Ah, they're not so bad.
They're not so bad kind of makes me wish now I get it- *high pitched* oh pewdiepie you were better-
You're right. You're right. You were right all along. I think people look at these montages and they you know, it's a snippet
It's a three second clip if I did a funny montage now. Oh boy. Oh boy
You would be... you would be very happy...
I remember this.
What is that laugh dude.
I was really not that funny. Next up we had flappy bird
I remember I played this game and then right after it completely blew up. I didn't even play flappy bird in this video.
I played Dumb Ways To Die, which is also an amazing game, but then I afterwards I played flappy bird bad sense being the genius
I am I changed the title and the thumbnail to flappy bird and
There you go. Boom 35 million views Thank You Felix. You greedy bastard next up
We have the video where I said, I would delete my channel. The biggest "It´s just a prank bro" in history
I didn't think anyone would actually believe me. I didn't think people would be like, "oh my god, is he actually gonna do it?"
I don't even remember why at least I don't remember the reason why I think I remember in the headspace
I was I was really fed up with being in the position. I was it's two months before the disaster
I didn't like being the biggest channel. I didn't like
Having so much attention to me
I've said it many times that I would rather just be a smaller channel so I could just do my own thing and
Literally no one would care
Like I never asked to be in this position
I genuinely felt like I can actually delete my channel and just start a new one. At that time
I was working with a lot of different people, you know
I had companies and stuff like that. And I knew that if I deleted my channel, it would be a huge
repercussion for
Other people so I I knew I couldn't do it but I did genuinely consider it. Scare PewDiePie never came out anyway
so, you know.
I could have just done it I should have just done it. Damn it. Next up. We have my draw my life video
I got accepted to my first choice of university and
Everything seemed fine. *piano music*
I started to become more creative *piano music continues*
That's really not a good video I feel like I could have done that a lot better
Then we have literally Jake Paul and Logan Paul
I guess people like hearing someone sh*t on Jake and Logan.
Next up we had the brofist by Roomie
So when you upload every single day if anyone comes to you and say hey
I can get you a video covered for that day. Yes, please
Yes
I will take it and Roomie came to me with this song that he made he spent a long time
On this song and he did an amazing job on it. So I mean I get free views. Roomie gets great exposure
He's a talented dude. And yeah, it's an amazing video. I had nothing to do with it. Literally nothing
It's a really good song
"No Swear Electric Challenge (The
Impossible Game). Good title Felix, very good title.
That actually hurts by the way, it genuinely hurts. Don't use that on your own your kids. I almost said
Don't use that on your pets and your kids. Oh
Look at me I'm like crying almost.
This is a weird period in YouTube where
*think of it Felix*
Punishment and video game was somehow a popular trend like the hot pepper or hot sauce if you die or you
Would do all these challenges. It's just like I'm glad that trend is over
Okay, because it was not fun. This video got demonetized because...
Damn it
It's a great video I'm not gonna show it it's hilarious. You should watch it
It's basically me and and Brad s..tposting at its finest and then of course that try not to laugh challenge
So here's seven months ago a year ago a year ago six months ago
So there are a lot of their recent ones. It's just the top ones are really
Like long ago, this is really fun. I really genuinely enjoyed reflecting a little bit on the past and
and uh not necessarily cringing just
In an endearing way I felt like. That was my most popular videos. Have you checked them out yet? What do you think?
*Bring back old pewdiepie. I prefer old pew-*
Me too, trust me, me, too
You think I want to be like this, huh?
It's interesting because you have my you see the difference everyone changes, but it's nice to see
it's nice to
See some growth and some change in in a in a positive way, but also not just completely hating your past. I don't know
It's kind of cool like eight years is a long time.
I'm lucky to still be here and I think about that all the time. So thank you everyone that keeps supporting the channel
honestly, I wouldn't be here without you and
Also
Double thank you if you buy the merch. All right, you're supposed to layer it, okay
I spend a lot of time on it, please. Thank you
It's got Walmart quality. Bye
*Bring the ASS outro everybody*
GOD
Buy the merch please guys